- [Voiceover] We're
in Austin, Texas, man.
It's hot
and I'm hopin' to see some
real down south racism.
- How the fuck are you today?
Yee-haw!
You guys look fan-terrible.
What this is is two
comedians going mic to mic.
- Pat Dean doesn't know the
meaning of the word "can't",
but let's try this one more time
you can't keep
molesting children.
- Kath Barbadoro
is what's happened
when you're born with a
ton of white privilege
but you use it all to skip
the line at CiCi's pizza.
- Feelings get hurt sometimes.
- I don't wanna to tell you that
Martin Arbono is pretentious
but when he drinks cum
he sticks his pinky out.
- You can say anything
you want in a roast show
as long as it's
funny as it is mean.
- If someone can
put the thought in
to make a great
burn at your expense
like they thought about it.
- Yeah yeah yeah a lot of work.
- And like that is so awesome.
- Jay's grandma is here.
How can you beat that?
I mean, even though I
think she should have died
a long time ago his
ancestors should've ended
with a peanut allergy.
- Chris Cubas is the
guy Hogwarts sends
when Hagrid decides the
neighborhood is too dangerous.
- Weird like their slogan is.
- You smiling scares the
fuckin' shit out of me.
- Ashley looks like she
just poisoned her husband.
- They're really biting.
They're really mean.
But, overall they're
really funny.
- Check our show out this
July on Comedy Central.
Thank you, everybody.